welcome back to las vegas now happy
bonus days from the clark county credit
union the sponsors of this next segment
here's how they're gifting the community
for the holidays
craig welcome back
thank you good to see you good to see
you too i hear you're done with your
holiday shopping already pretty much
grandkids are done and we're really
close to being done
wow well that is perfect timing because
you are actually giving a gift to the
community as well let's talk about your
happy bones days
absolutely we're kicking off the gift
gift-giving season this year by bringing
back happy bonus days for the second
time it's a week-long event where we
give back to both the community and our
members and how can the community and
people get involved in happy bonus days
all our members have to do is use their
clark county credit union visa reward
card between thanksgiving and cyber
monday every time they use their card
during that week it creates an entry
into a drawing where they have a chance
to win one of the happy bones day
payoffs
ooh and what is the big giveaway what's
the payoff
absolutely what happens is all they have
to do is use their card during that week
and then
the second week of december every day
during that week a member will be
randomly selected and their visa balance
will be paid off up to fifteen hundred
dollars each
we're also giving five fifteen hundred
dollars uh to five non-profits here in
the valley to help further their cause
as well now those were voted on by the
employees i wrote them down so i don't
forget who they are
they will be ronald mcdonald house
project 150 nevada partnership for
homeless youth plus
care or cure for the kids and nspca so
they'll all be receiving fifteen hundred
dollars to help further their causes
that is amazing and if someone doesn't
have this credit card how do they get
involved what do they need to do
right now is a great time to apply with
our visa card with the rates as low as
8.90
the rewards can be traded in for cash
travel benefits charitable contributions
and and more to apply for a card simply
call us at 228 2228 or visit our website
at ccculv.org
perfect and like i said you have already
done most of your holiday shopping so
what advice do you have for consumers
out there who are preparing to do theirs
besides
yes that's the first step start early
you don't have to wait till december to
start make a list of who you want to
purchase for then create a budget that
makes sense to you stay within that
budget and if you use your credit cards
wisely it actually helps build credit
and here's a tip more for next year
because it'll help then start a clark
county accreditation christmas club
account then every payday you just have
so much thrown into that account
automatically and then when november
rolls around you don't have to worry
about where you're going to get your
holiday spending money it's going to be
there for you ah see that's the secret
thank you guys you guys do so much for
us we appreciate you oh well we
appreciate you having us thank you so
much of course happy holidays craig you
too have a great holiday we'll see you
soon
thank you to clark county credit union
for sponsoring this segment give them a
call at 702-228-2228
or visit
ccculv.org they have a special offer for
you you could win up to fifteen hundred
dollars paid off on your cccu credit
card so make sure you apply for that
today jillian